[Musique]
mais lundi 29 novembre la communauté
juive s'est rassemblée sur la place
estienne franchois choisel à montigny le
bretonneux pour célébrer ensemble
hanoukka ou autrement dit la fête de la
lumière dans ce sens et la fête de
hanouka raluca qui veut dire en fait
inauguré il avait cette branche dans le
chandelier du temple mais le but
chandelier à sept branches a brûlé
miraculeusement durant huit jours
aujourd'hui nous allumons ce même champ
donner aux commémorations de ce miracle
de cette furie qui a brûlé durant huit
jours une symbolique forte pour les
fidèles puisque ce miracle a eu lieu
durant la domination des grecs mais il y
a un grand message dire que tous passent
aux entendent obscurité dans un temps où
l'oppression la force brutale semble
l'emporter et qu'est ce qu'il gagne
finalement c'est une lumière en réalité
le message encore une fois n'est pas un
message limité à la communauté juive ou
limiter un endroit donné c'est
littéralement un message universel une
célébration plein de musique et de danse
pour véhiculer ce message de paix et de
rassemblement c'est aussi une
manifestation d'une
d'habitants de personnes qui célèbrent
la fête des lumières avec derrière des
messages très positif et donc je pense
que c'est bien d'être présent avec à
leurs côtés cette année la communauté
juive de saint quentin en yvelines a
voulu faire les choses en grand avec
l'organisation d'un spectacle
pyrotechnique et l'installation d'une
menora géante en glace or ces sculptures
en glace j'aime on m'a trouvé ça marrant
le symbole un peu la jonction du feu et
de la glace la tradition veut que
l'allumage se fasse à la tombée de la
nuit chaque jour une nouvelle bougie
vient s'ajouter à la menora au sein des
foyers